quatre chars j'avoue avoir du beau linge
mais ces chantiers le samedi rance pow
je reviens correct et même combat breaké
au restaurant ne connaissent souvent des
files désastreuse de juin ben oui
[Musique]
je m'appelle claire et dao
je suis né le 18 novembre en 1932 sur
une ferme à saint-eustache et j'ai 86
ans ce que j'aime dans la vie c'est mon
show wilson mes oiseaux la motoneige la
famille
la nature et la rivière aussi et tape
dessus tout travailler sur un chantier
quand les eaux se présenter c'est le
coup de foudre à peu près un an avant
notre mariage et s'étend à l'est dans la
construction tireur de joints
puis comme les ornais pas à faire la
collection j'allais collecter les
constructeurs quand on travaillait dans
la périphérie
quand je les appelais pour préparer leur
chèque j'étais tenace et et moi et puis
on tombe d'accord c'est un peu moins
qu'à l'air par un ferment voit ici c'est
un ami je me sens
[Musique]
pour sa part la suite
là il m'entraîne y est allé travailler
avec lui ça les encourage un geste est
heureusement une crise car c'est à la
maison c'est sûr qu'on est jeunes on
était quand même amoureux fait que subit
un coin est un pur hasard une taxe est
fait mais ce cette époque jean marc
caisso mais c'était super de travailler
tout beau tout est dû merci sûr quand
j'ai commencé à aller sur les chantiers
pour un travail ils mettront un disait
salut tu rigoles un bonjour ma tante
daigné déniaisé ça me dérange pas je vis
ça me dérange pas qu'ils semblent rien
bonjour les lobbys leur jeu pour gêner
bucheton seuil est il y avait beaucoup
de femmes les portent ce jeu les
chantiers le site a peut-être des
premiers jeux d'ego jaune parce que
quand on recommence mais ton lien à 7h
et 8h le plus tard mais si souvent 7
heures 7 heures et demie le temps de
sortie chantier et puis il ya des fois
qu'on revienne au pouvoir on va
travailler jusqu'à 7,8 en juillet leon à
modérer un peu mais on a travaillé
beaucoup le même le dimanche
des fois ils disent vous n'êtes pas
fatigué je te promets non monsieur
parfaite ce qui est vrai que ça nous
donne je donne à la claque mais moi si
j'ai bonne santé je lui ai je
prolongeais pour le maire c'est ça qui
nous tient informés ils vont toujours
mon nez tant que joueur est capable des
gays je les aime super channel qui
m'amènerait projet ray brouilla lot
on dirait que je me sens comme un corps
jeune parce que si je me sentais bien
vieille me décide à la fois travailler
quand je veux finir par être obligés
d'arrêter ça c'est sûr mais je m'arrête
pas comme si j'avais un étage pour le
matin au pied la [ __ ] dans le tapis
[Musique]
jeter encore vivante j'ai encore jean r
captage et moi non